j'ai évidemment une pensée toute
particulière pour les quatre orphelins
pour les veuves pour toute la
gendarmerie nationale pour toutes les
forces de l'ordre qui connaissent parce
g l'un des événements les plus tragiques
de son histoire et cela me permet de
vous rappeler également que avec les
trois gendarmes décédé cette nuit c'est
la onzième décès depuis le début de
l'année des forces de l'ordre en
opération n'appartient pas de revenir
sur les circonstances de ce drame se
porter la république s'est saisie mais
de dire notamment ces fêtes de noël où
les français seront encore protégé par
les forces de l'ordre et les policiers
des gendarmes la gendarmerie nationale
fait un travail quotidien de protection
de nos concitoyens et que nous leur
devons respect et reconnaissance
j'ai tenu toute la nuit informé monsieur
le président de la république et
monsieur le premier ministre qui se sont
exprimés ce matin pour dire à quel point
également ce drame touche et notre
nation tout entière dans ce département
du puy de dôme dans cette brigade de
gendarmerie d'ambert dans ce village de
saint-just et que nos coeurs nous pensé
aller évidemment à tous ceux ces femmes
et ces hommes qui risquent leur vie
je voudrais aussi avoir un mot pour tous
les services de l'état les gendarmes qui
sont intervenus en soutien de leurs
camarades et qui sous les feux des
assassins ont protégé cette femme et son
enfant et l'ont mis à l'abri
une pensée également pour le gendarme
blessé qui courageusement à plusieurs
reprises et malgré ses blessures a voulu
accomplir sa mission
nous leur devons donc respect je
remercie